Australia's wild dog the dingo is on the
prowl
today it hunts alone a sign the dingo is
probably on the lookout for small but it
senses a larger opportunity a baby
kangaroo called a Joey makes an
excellent target it's too big for his
mother to carry if she has to run away
the dingo slings forward while the Joey
unaware keeps busy grooming himself his
mother senses a nearby predator but it's
not the dingo her attention is fixed on
the wedge tailed eagle flying above his
mother calls Joey to her side
[Music]
neither one sees the dingo approaching
through the brush for a moment a young
male freezes
[Music]
his panic keeps contagious the mother
and her Joey make their getaway to the
dingo bursts after the ruse the dingoes
no slouch when it comes to speed but the
Roos reach 35 miles per hour
dingoes have better luck hunting in
packs when they're after large kangaroos
it's back to searching for prey that's
not so big and not so fast